du nouveau dans l'affairé omar raddad
son jardinier accusé du meurtre de sa
patronne a passé sept ans en prison
avant d'être graciés
aujourd'hui deux expertises
graphologiques indique que l'inscription
omar m'a tuer n'aurait pas été écrite
par la victime ghislaine marchal les
explications d'isabelle sabouraud et
emmanuel gagner omar m'a tuer lors du
procès en assises ces quelques lettres
avaient emporté la conviction des jurés
quelques lettres de sang que la victime
ghislaine marchal aurait tracé dans un
dernier souffle pour désigner son
assassin c'est sur la foi de cette
inscription comme à raddad le jardinier
qui a toujours clamé son innocence fut
condamné à 18 ans de réclusion
criminelle
mais aujourd'hui six ans plus tard de
nouvelles simulations réalisées par deux
graphologue viennent contredire les
premiers experts
rien ne prouve que ces quelques mots
sont ceux de ghislaine marshall une
victoire pour maître vergès
les experts ont essayé de savoir si
quelqu'un dans l'obscurité
lagrave bourg blessés se tenant sur une
main prouvées de l'autre tremper ses
doigts dans son ventre et écrire des
lettres aussi aligné comme au cordeau ça
ça n'a pas été fait par les premiers
experts les nouvelles expertises
graphologiques ont été ordonnées par la
justice après la demande de révision du
procès obtenu en janvier 99 par maître
vergès une révision attendue avec
impatience par marc haddad gracié et
libéré en septembre 98 après sept ans de
prison il vit actuellement à marseille
il a refait sa vie mais il estime que
seul un procès en révision pourrait lui
restituer son honneur